These are some ways that you can use the
technology we discussed in this course.
And what I love about
each of these examples,
is that you can hardly
see the technology.
Some people think that the future of
computing is keeping you immersed, and
keeping you away from you life.
But as it turns out,
with ubiquitous computing, less is more.
It's where we,
as developers and designers,
put the user before the technology.
As we remove the abstract barriers,
such as what functionality
resides on what device.
Our users can focus more
on what they're doing, and
less on how to start doing it.
Now, this simple core philosophy
to ubiquitous computing
is what you see over and
over again in terms like seamless,
simple, microinteraction,
and glanceable.
And it's not new.
It's the idea that success isn't
measured by how long the user is engaged
with the interface, but how quickly
we can get them to what they need.
Now there's a website that's been
around for just over 15 years,
that was built with that
philosophy in mind.
Google.
This kind of user
interaction is in our DNA.
Back at a time when the search engine
philosophy was to keep the user
on the page as long as possible,
Google went the other direction.
And as it turns out,
that's exactly what users wanted.
And that's why it made sense for
us to recognize that as a core
philosophy across all
these new form factors.